nutrition is very important because you
have to treat your body like like a
machine almost if you don't give it at
the right and then necessary fuel it
needs that it don't it'll fail even
young it's everything I mean if you
don't have good nutrition you're not
going to be able to ride your bike it's
just simple as that
so I like to break down the nutritional
considerations between firstly based on
energy USA Cycling prefer to use the SAS
go isotonic NH gel what they'll try and
answer is take on around 60 to 90 grams
of carbohydrates our and gels provide
really easy solution to Taylor on the
isotonic gels are really good cuz they
transport really easily for the guys and
they're having a lot less issues with GI
distress
I found a Eve moralist with the sis
stuff because I don't like having
anything that's too too hard for my
stomach and the gels are super easy to
get down so I find them just eating more
of them while I'm riding which keeps me
better fueled when I'm towards the end
of the race to the Apple Jail it tastes
super good and my go-to for last 10kv
risk we use multi veteran of the main
ingredient in our tonic any details
along with warfare which actually
provides an isotonic gel now compared to
a hypertonic solution the isotonic means
the concentration of that gel is the
same as what's in the body I generally
am not big into eating gels but with the
science and score gels they're thinner
and really the taste is more natural a
lot of cyclists find that when I take
these hypotonic concentrated gels on the
bike they can get a lot of stomach
cramps stomach upset now taking an
isotonic energy gel can help combat that
solution by providing the body's we can
digest overly
that's been a huge help as far as
getting rid of nutrition during the race
it's hard to digest the whole bar so you
can just grab a few gels and just get
those down quickly and get the nutrition
we need also a big fan of the testing
protocols that science is for uses for
me as an athlete that's that's really
big you know you have so many so many
people relying on you sponsors and
friends and family and you know one bad
test can can ruin all that and I really
take a reputation and I think that you
know when you can be sure that what
you're putting into your body is clean
and safe but all you have to do is just
focus on focus on racing nice